[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
الصيني ممتده تبكين غاضبه لاسقاطه وواشنطن
تسعى لكشف اسراره او ما تبقى منها
عيش الفرنسيون قلقا مستمرا من حدوث ازمه
وقود في البلاد هذا القلق وربما تبدا قيود
الديزل الروسي العربيه ترصد التداعيات من
محطات الوقود وبكين لا تزال طوق نجاه
لموسكو
مع احياء ذكرى ثوره الخميني يوابل
انتقادات من خاتمي وموسوي للنظام وتقارير
تكشف رواتب ميليشياته
لدينا ايضا
عبر اجتماع لوفود عسكريه تركيا تكشف عن
خطوه جديده للتطبيع مع دمشق هذا الشهر
لكنها تتحفظ على التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
انتهت ازمه تحليق المنطاد الصينيه فوق
الاراضي الامريكيه لكن ازمه اسقاطه بدات
الصين غاضبه بدعوى المبالغه في رد الفعل
مع هدف مدني والبنتاجون لا يزال يحاول فك
لغز المنطاد عبر تجميع حطامه وحتى في
الولايات المتحده يدور الجدل حول ما اذا
كانت واشنطن اتخذت الخيارات الاصح منذ
بدايه ازمه المنطاد حتى الان
هو البالون الذي اغضب واشنطن واحدث هزه
دبلوماسيه جديده في علاقتها مع بكين سبعه
ايام قضاها المنطاد محلقا فوق امريكا
الشماليه قبل ان يتعرض للاستهداف وفق
نيويورك تايمز في هذا اليوم دخل المنطاد
وانحرف نحو المجال الجوي لاسكا بالقرب من
جزر الوشيان بحلول نهايه هذا اليوم خرج
المنطاد من الاراضي الامريكيه ثم عاود
المنطاد دخول الولايات المتحده فوق ايداه
وشق المنطاد طريقه الى السماء فوق بلينجز
اكبر مدن ولايه مونتانا التي توجد بها
قاعده مالمستروم الجويه التي تضم 150
مستودعا للصواريخ الباليستيه العابره
للقارات فيما اوردت التقارير ان منطادا
صينيا ثانيا يسافر عبر امريكا الوسطى
متجها نحو امريكا الجنوبيه بكين ذكرت من
جانبها ان البالون هو بالون طقس انحرف عن
مساره متاثرا بالرياح الغربيه اما في هذا
اليوم فاسقطت مقاتله من طراز اف 22
المنطقه الصيني فوق المحيط الاطلسي قباله
الساحل الشرقي للولايات المتحده تلك هي
رحله المنطاد الذي تسبب في الغاء زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الى بكين
كما اغتنمها الجمهوريون فرصه اخرى لمهاجمه
بايدن انتقادا لعدم اتخاذ اجراءات اكثر
صرامه ضد المنطاد وضد مطلقته الصين
السجال السياسيه بين واشنطن مستمر حتى بعد
سقوط المنطاد الصيني ولا يتوقع اي طرف ان
ينتهي قريبا فاسئله عديدا سالت الان حول
ما يمكن ايجاده داخل المنطاد وهل فعلا هو
منطاد تجسس كما تزعم الولايات المتحده ام
انه من تضم مدني لبحث الارصاد الجويه كما
تدعي الصين حاليا فان الترقب يسود حول
نتائج تحليل بقايا مكونات المنطاد علما ان
اجزاء منه قد تكون تعرضت للتلف في المياه
او للتفكك بسبب تاثير ضربه الصاروخ
الامريكي الذي استخدم لاسقاطه بقايا
المنطاد من المفترض ان ترسل الى مختبر
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه بولايه
فيرجينيا حيث سيتكفل بتحليله خبراء في
وكالات الاستخبارات
وبحسب اولى المعلومات التي عرضها
البانتاجون فان المنطاد يحمل اجهزه
استشعار ومعدات مراقبه ويمكنه بذلك القيام
بعده مناورات وقد اظهر انه يمكن ان يغير
مساره حسين الطاوود معه المزيد من
التفاصيل
تاخر اسقاط المنطاد الصيني حتى يوم السبت
اثار الكثير من الجدل الديمقراطيون يرون
ان الاداره الامريكيه وزاره الدفاع
تصرفتها بطريقه صحيحه بانتظاره حتى يصبح
فوق المحيط الاطلسي واسقطوه كي لا يتسبب
بوقوع اصابات بين المواطنين في المقابل
يرى الجمهوريون بان تاخر اداره الرئيس
بايدن باسقاط المنطاد ترك له حريه التحليق
فوق الولايات المتحده وجمع المعلومات
وتعريض امن البلاد للخطر واعتبروا التاخير
عرضا محرجا للضعف وفشلا للامن القومي
واذا سلمنا فعلا بان هذا المنطاد كان غرضه
التجسس كما تقول واشنطن فلا يزال السؤال
الاهم قائما ما سبب لجوء الصين الى هذه
الوسيله للتجسس في عصر الاقمار الصناعيه
هناك معطيات تبرر استخدام منطاد للتجسس
قياسا بالمميزات التي يتوفر عليها والتي
تغيب عن الاجهزه الحديثه الاخرى بهذا
الخصوص يقول وليمكم المتخصص في مناطيد
المراقبه في مركز ابحاث ماراثون في واشنطن
ان المنطاد قد يتوفر على ادوات تشتغل
بالذكاء الاصطناعي وهي احيانا تكون ادوات
متطوره قادره على رصد اهداف النوعيه وعلى
العكس من الاقمار الصناعيه المعرضه بشكل
متزايد للهجمات الارضيه والفضائيه فان
المناطيد تتمتع بقدرتها على التخفي من
الرادار لانها مصنوعه من مواد غير معدنيه
لا تعكس الضوء
ودائما اذا ما افترضنا ان المنطاد كان
للتجسس فما الذي كانت تسعى اليه الصين
تقول صحيفه واشنطن بوست بهذا الخصوص ان
المنطاد ربما استخدم الاختبار قدره امريكا
على اكتشاف التهديدات القادمه وايجاد
ثغرات في نظام انذار الدفاع الجوي للبلاد
كما قد يسمح ايضا المنطاد للصينيين
باستشعار الانبعاثات الكهرومغناطيسيه التي
لا تستطيع الاقمار الصناعيه عاليه
الارتفاع ان تكتشفها كالترددات اللاسلكيه
منخفضه الطاقه التي يمكن ان تساعدهم في
فهم كيفيه التواصل بين انظمه الاسلحه
الامريكيه المختلفه
ما يعزز هذه الاطروحه هو ان الحادثه نسفت
محاولات تهدئه التوتر بين امريكا والصين
علما ان الرئيس الصيني
كان ابدى
نيه في تحسين العلاقات وليس العكس من خلال
ترحيبه بزياره بلنكم التي لم تتم
وفيما يتعلق بردود فعل الطرفين فقد وصفت
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه اقتحام من طرد
المراقبه المجال الجوي الامريكي بانه غير
مقبول وغير مسؤول على الطرف الاخر فان
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الصينيه اعرب
عن احتجاج بلاده الشديد على قيام الولايات
المتحده باسقاط منقادها المدني بدون طيار
مضيفا ان بكين تحتفظ بالحق في استخدام
الوسائل الضروريه للتعامل مع مواقف مماثله
وفي تطور اخر اعلنت السلطات الصينيه اقاله
رئيس هيئه الارصاد الجويه حيث حملته
المسؤوليه مسؤوليه انحراف المنطاد الى
امريكا قد تكون هذه مناوره صينيه لحرف
الانظار عن حقيقه المنطاد وقد لا تكون هذا
التساؤل وغيره نناقشه بعد قليل مع ضيفنا
من واشنطن مدير مركز التحليل السياسي
العسكري في معهد
اهلا بك معنا استاذ ريتشرد
ونسالك اولا عن الجدل الدائر في داخل
الولايات المتحده كما الجدل الاخر الدائر
على الضفه الاخرى في الصين عما اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قد تعاملت
بالطريقه الامثل والانسب مع هكذا موضوع او
انه تم استغلاله وتضخيم حجمه من اجل مكاسب
سياسيه معينه
انت محقه تمت بعض الامور ذات الصله
بالاستغلال السياسي داخل الولايات المتحده
فهناك بعض الجمهوريه الذين قالوا انه كان
ينبغي اسقاط هذا المونتاج قبل ان يدخل الى
الاجواء الامريكيه
والديمقراطيون دافعوا عن قرار الرئيس
بايدن بشان عدم تفجير
المنطاد فوق مدرسه او شيء من هذا القبيل
وهذا ربما قد يعود
لاعتبارات سياسيه ولكن اعتقد اننا سوف
نشهد الكثير من هذا الجدل خلال الانتخابات
المقبله ايضا نقصنا فرضيه ان هناك جهات في
الصين قد لا تكون راضيه عما وصل اليه
البلدان قبيل زياره بلينكن الى بكين من
توافق على الاقل من قبول للتفاوض على
الاقل من لقاءات على هذا المستوى هل لنا
ان نناقش فرضيه اخرى موازيه في الولايات
المتحده عن جهات ارادت تغيير هذا المسار
واستغلت موضوع المنطاد لكي ترجئ زياره
بلنكن
لقد سمعت
هاتين الفرضيتين اما اراه شخصيا هو ان
الجيش الصيني ربما لديه
ثلاثه او اربعه او ثلاثين او اربعين من
هذا القبيل وربما لم يتم التنسيق مع
القياده السياسيه وهذا المنطاد ربما تم
ارساله في الوقت غير المناسب لاننا وجهنا
مماثل في
1997 عندما اسقطت الصين قمرا صناعيا صيني
وفي ظل
تقارب الصيني امريكي وهناك ربما من راى ان
اتخاذ القرار طبعا قد يكون قرارا عسكريا
بعيد عن
القياده السياسيه قد يكون هناك ربما يرغب
في افشال هذه الزياره ولكن اعتقد انه لم
يكن هناك معارضه قويه في الولايات المتحده
بشان هذه الزياره ولكن بعد حدوث ازمه
المنطقه فكان واجب الغاء الزياره لان
فان التركيز كان سيكون على المنطاد اثناء
الزياره بدلا من بحث امور اخرى ووسائل
الاعلام الصينيه تقول ان الولايات المتحده
استغلت الازمه لتاجيل الزياره لقد شهدت
امور من هذا القبيل في السابق
فهناك طبعا مهاجمه
للسفاره الصينيه في اغراض من طرف الجيش
الامريكي في السابق ان لم اتفاجا بما حدث
حتى الان
وحوادث التجسس قديمه ومعروفه بين الط هذا
ليس جديدا ولكن يبدو انه الموضوع الان بعد
كشفه
سيعتمد كثيرا على طبيعه المواد التي
ستكتشفها الولايات المتحده في هذا المنطاد
بعد تحليله وعلى ما ارادت الصين من وراء
هذا المنطاد وهذا سيحدد ربما طبيعه
العلاقات بين الطرفين في الفتره المقبله
استاذ ريتشارد
نعم لدينا ايضا مثال تاريخي رائع كهذا في
الستينات القرن الماضي قامت الولايات
المتحده
بارسال قمر صناعي فوق
الاتحاد السوفياتي وقد تم اسقاطه وداعت
الولايات المتحده بان الصاروخ كان او
القمر الصناعي كان الاغراض الجويه كما
فعلت الصين الان ولكن بعدما قات الولايات
المتحده فان
الاتحاد السوفيتي عرض بقايا القمر الصناعي
على وسائل الاعلام واثبتت
عدم صحه ما قالته الولايات المتحده
مركز تحليل السياسي العسكري في معهد شكرا
جزيلا لك على وجودك معنا الليله تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
وفي العربيات 360 ايضا
افراز خامنا عن معتقلين هديه في نظر
النظام والدعايه في نظر الجمعيات الحقوقيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذن اكسيوس تنقل عن
جمهوريين في مجلس النواب الامريكي انهم
يخططون للتحقيق في استجابه جو بايدن
الرئيس الامريكي لازمه المنطاد وهو
موضوعنا الاساس الذي ناقشناه قبل قليل في
العربيه 360 ونتابع فيها من الملف
الاوكراني فقد اكد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
والاكسير ان الاسلحه البعيده المدى التي
وعد بها الغرب بلاده لن تستخدم لاستهداف
روسيا وانما للمناطق المحتله فقط
ربما قراتم بالفعل ان شركائنا الاميركيين
قرروا يوم الجمعه تزويدنا باسلحه قادره
على اطلاق النار على مسافه 150 كم نقول
دائما لشركائنا اننا نلتزم بعدم استخدام
الاسلحه المقدمه من الشركاء الاجانب ضد
اراضي روسيا ولكن فقط ضد وحداتها في
الاراضي المحتله مؤقتا اوكرانيا
في المقابل اعتبرت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان قوات دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي حاضره بالفعل في اوكرانيا منذ
اكثر من عام على شكل مدربين وهيئه امنيه
وشككت زخرفه في عقلانيه تفكير مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي الذي
اكد ان الاتحاد لن يرسل قوات للمشاركه في
الصراع
لكن ليست دعم العسكري فقط هو ما يؤرق
روسيا وانما ايضا حزمه العقوبات الاوروبيه
المفروضه عليها فالحرب الاقتصاديه بين
روسيا والغرب تشتد وتدخل منعرجا حاسما
خاصه فيما يتعلق بعصب الاقتصاد الروسي
صادرات الطاقه منذ بدايه هذا اليوم دخلت
حزمه عقوبات اوروبيه وغربيه حيز التنفيذ
وتستهدف حظر مشتقات الوقود الروسيه ضمن
جهود لخفض المداخيل الماليه لموسكو وتشمل
هذه العقوبات تحديدا سقف سعر الاضافي على
المنتجات البتروليه الروسيه
سقف اسعار المنتجات البتروريه ذات الجوده
العاليه
هو 100 دولار للبرميل
اما المنتجات البتروليه الاخرى مثل زيت
الوقود والنفته فان سقف سعرها خمسه
واربعين دولارا للبرميل وتعني هذه العقوبه
ان اي دوله تسعى لشراء النفط الروسي لن
تكون قادره على القيام بذلك الا اذا دفعت
اقل من الحد الاقصى كما ان الشركات
الاوروبيه والبريطانيه لن تقوم بتامين اي
شحنه لا تستجيب لهذا الشرط وضع جديد
تواجهه روسيا الان التي ستحتاج الى البحث
عن مشترين بدلاء لما يقرب من 600 الف
برميل كانت ترسلها سابقا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي يوميا بالاضافه الى البحث عن
اساطير بديله لنقل الشحن بعد توقف تعاملها
مع السفن الغربيه لنقل تلك الشحن وقد تخسر
روسيا
160 مليون يورو يوميا وذلك بحسب تصريحات
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
لكن من شان العقوبات الاخيره ان تنعكس
سلبا على السوق الاوروبيه خاصه وان اوروبا
تحصل على اكثر من نصف وارداتها من الديزل
من روسيا ولم تجد امدادات كافيه حتى الان
ما قد يؤدي الى ارتفاع الاسعار ثدي دهوك
معه المزيد من باريس
يعيش الفرنسيون قلقا مستمرا من حدوث ازمه
وقود في البلاد هذا القلق نابع بالدرجه
الاولى من تهديد النقابات باضرابات ستشمل
حقول الضخ ما سيعطل حركه تزويد المحطات
بالوقود هذه الاضرابات تاتي في سياق
اقتصادي ضاغط فرضته الحرب في اوكرانيا ما
تسبب بزياده الاسعار وزياده نسب التضخم اذ
قفزت اسعار المواد البتروليه الى ارقام
غير مسبوقه فاقترب سعر لتر الديزل على
سبيل المثال الى اليوروهين والنصف
الحكومه تدخلت في السابق لخفض الاسعار لكن
ذلك كان لمده انقضت مع نهايه العام 2022
اما الان فهناك مساعده بدات الحكومه
بدفعها لاصحاب الدخل المحدود من اولئك
الذين يستخدمون سياراتهم في الذهاب الى
العمل فادي الدهوك العربيه باريس
العقوبات الغربيه تواصل تشديد الخناق على
روسيا لحرمانها من تمويل عملياتها
العسكريه لكن كما نجحت موسكو في الالتفاف
على الحزم السابقه تحاول التغلب على الحزم
الجديده بمساعده اطراف عده ومن بينها
الصين نقلا عن تقرير لصحيفه وست جارنا
الامريكيه فان الصين باتت مصدرا مزودا
لروسيا بعده مكونات لم تعد تصلها بسبب
العقوبات خاصه المواد ذات الاستخدام
العسكري فالصين تقدم تكنولوجيا الحربيه
التي يحتاجها الجيش الروسي وذلك نقلا عن
بيانات الجمارك الروسيه التي حصلت عليها
الصحيفه تظهر السجلات الجمركيه ان شركات
الدفاع الصينيه المملوكه للدوله تشحن
معدات الملاحه وقطع الغيار للطائرات
المقاتله الى شركات الدفاع المملوكه
للحكومه الروسيه والخاضعه للعقوبات كما هو
معلوم
ومن بين الشحنات قطع غيار ارسلت الى شركات
تصنيع الصواريخ الروسيه المملوكه للدوله
الماز انتي وتظهر في البيانات ايضا شحنات
من المسيرات الصينيه والتي يقول دي جي اي
محللون عسكريون ان القوات الروسيه
تستخدمها لتحديد موقع القوات الاوكرانيه
موسكو وتكين نفتاء الاتهامات الموجهه
اليهما حيث اكتفت روسيا بالقول ان لديها
امكانات تكنولوجيه كافيه لضمان امنها
وتامين العمليه العسكريه الخاصه وذلك نقلا
عن المتحدث باسم الكرامل
اما الصين فقد ردت على لسان المتحدث باسم
سفارتها في واشنطن
ان الادعاء بان الصين تقدم مساعدات لروسيا
ليس له اساس واقعي وهو مجرد تكهنات وتضخيم
متعمد
ورغبه في وقف هذه المساعدات الصينيه قالت
واشنطن انها بصدد تجهيز عقوبات ضد اهداف
جديده يعتقد انها تسهل حرب الكرملين وياتي
ملف دعم الصين لروسيا ليضاف الى الملفات
الاخرى التي تشعل التوتر بين بكين وواشنطن
علما انه كان من المقرر مناقشه هذا الملف
خلال زياره
التي اجلت بسبب حادثه المنطاد الصيني وهو
موضوعنا الاول في العربيه 360 معنى من
باريس الان الباحث الاقتصادي دكتور دانيال
ملحم لنساله عن هذه الامور هل تعتقد اهلا
بك دكتور دانيال هل تعتقد بانه يعني
عقوبات جديده على الصين بسبب روسيا ستكون
في صالح علاقه الولايات المتحده مع الصين
وهي التي كانت تحاول ان تديرها على الاقل
في حاله من اداره الصراع ان لم يكن حل
طبعا
تحيه لك سيدي والمشاهدين الكرام اليوم
العقوبات خاصه على دوله الصين اللي تعتبر
ثاني اقتصاد العالم لتعتبر هي المركز
الرئيسي او المخزن او المصنع الرئيسي
للعالم اعتقد لا تفيد احدا حتى حتى
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا اوروبا
ولا احد وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان اليوم
الكلام عن فرض عقوبات على الصين
ليس ليس لها لديه اي جدوى فقط هناك بعض
العقوبات التي تفرط على بعض القطاعات
التكنولوجيه على على الاشباه الموصلات
وغيرها وبالتالي هي موجوده في الاصل هذه
وبالطريقه من تحت الطاوله وبالتالي اليوم
لا اعتقد ان يكون هناك عقوبات جديده على
على الصين خصوصا بعد تعاونها الاخير مع
روسيه وبموضوع اثرناه ايضا في العرض
السابق تحديد سقف سعر الطاقه الروسيه الى
اي مدى باعتقادك سيتم الالتزام وكيف
ستتمكن روسيا من الالتفاف
لم اعتقد اليوم حتى حتى اسعار النفط اليوم
هناك وضع وضع سقف للنفط منذ اكثر من شهرين
لليوم وبالتالي لا زال النفط ليصل الى
كثير من الدول الى الدول كالهند
كدول شركه اسيا هناك الكثير من الدول الى
تركيا الى المغرب وغيرها من الدول اعتقد
اليوم الضيق العرض في في سوق النفط
العالمي وخاصه من المشتقات النفطيه تعطني
عمليا ان ان لا يوجد حل الا بايصال اعتقد
ان الدول الغربيه اليوم سوف تغض النظر على
على ايصال هذه المواد وبالتالي سوف يكون
هناك اعاده رسم خريطه حركه التجاره وخاصه
المشتقات النفطيه وبالتالي سوف تستمر
الوصول الى اوروبا والولايات المتحده نحن
نشهد عمليا ان الهند زادت صدراتها بنسبه
200% الى الولايات المتحده واوروبا اضافه
لذلك ماليزيا المغرب اليوم نتكلم عن
المغرب وتركيا ايضا وحتى من الدول
كالسعوديه وهي لن تحصل على ولكن زادت
عمليا هذا لدى الصادرات هي والامارات
والكويت في الشهر في الشهر الماضي بنسبه
الضعفين لذلك عمليا ان اليوم لا يوجد
بدائل هي مستمره بهذه العقوبات هذه
العقوبات لن تجدي نفعا على المدى القصير
وبالتالي بدات الدول الغربيه تغض الطرف
عمليا لان اليوم هناك اشكاليه اشكاليه
تضخم وهي لا تريد فرض او زياده عوام
الاخرى خارجيه لزياده التضخم والتالي
مشاكلها الداخليه هي لا تريد زياده اضافه
عليها مشاكل خارجيه لكن اساسا رهان من قبل
الدول الغربيه التي تقوم بتنفيذ هذه
العقوبات على روسيا على الاقل يعني اليس
كل ذلك فيه رهان على المدى الطويل او
المتوسط على الاقل وليس القصير المتعلق
باشهر او بسنه فقط
نعم اليوم السقف العقوبات لا اعتقد انه
سيجدي نفعا لا يعلم المدى القصير ولا على
المدى الطويل اعتقد ان حجب التكنولوجيا عن
روسيه وحجب عنها بعض الامدادات الرئيسيه
لسوف يؤذي روسيا اكثر بكثير من وضع سقوفات
النقد نحن نتكلم اليوم عن ما بين 11 الى
15 مليار ووضع السقف النفط على على بحدود
الستين دولار او فتتاثر عمليا الميزانيه
الروسيه ب 16 مليار وهذا بعيد كليا عن 350
مليار لتجنيها سنويا نحن نتكلم اليوم عن
22 مليار دولار في حاله تخطى اسعار
المشتقات النفطيه 100 دولار وهذه عمليا
بعيد وخسر ديزل نحن نتكلم ولكن اليوم ما
نراه على الطاوله هو بعيد كليا الروسيه لن
تتاثر بوضع سقوف على هذه الاسعار اعتقد ان
الدول الغربيه هي تستخدم
ما بقي في جعبتها من بعض القارات ولكن هذا
القرارات ليس لها تاثير على مدى القصير
ولا نظر الطويل القرارات التي اتخذت قبل
او العقوبات التي فرضت قبل هي التي لديها
التاثير اكثر على المدى الطويل ولكن اليوم
اصبح واضحا ان السقوفات التي وضعت لن تجدي
نفعا واوروبا كيف يمكن ان يعني تجاري كل
ذلك حتى لو استطاعت ان تتخطم مرحله اولى
صعبه ولكن ايضا على المديين المتوسط وطويل
كيف سيمكنها الاستمرار هل الوقت في صالحها
او العكس
العمليا نعم هي تحاول شراء الوقت بالنسبه
لاوروبا وهنا الحلقه الاضعف في كل هذه
الدائره كلها اوروبا اليوم هي تقبل ان
تشتري من الاسواق الفوريه عمليا باسعار
مرتفعه جدا هناك دول تستطيع الدفع
كالمانيا ودول الشمال هناك الدول الجنوب
لن تستطيع الدفع بهذه الاسعار المرتفعه
اليوم هنا كان لدينا بشتاء 2022-2023
اليوم الاجواء سواء كانت الطقس او بعد
العوامل
الخارجيه صعدت اوروبا لتخطي هذا الشتاء
المؤسف ان يكون هناك الشتاء المقبل 2023
هو شتاء سوف يكون نوعا ما في حال اذا كان
هناك صقيع ام اعاده فتح الصين اعاده فتح
دول جنوب شرق اسيا من جديد وبالتالي عمليا
كل هذه العوامل سوف تضغط اكثر على اوروبا
ماذا يعني هذا ماذا يعني ان الميزان
التجاري الخارجي سوف يضعف نزال مدفوعات
سوف يضعف وهذا سوف يؤثر على قيمه اليورو
وسوف يدخل اوروبا عمليا في ركود سوف يكون
نوعا ما صعب خلال الش المقبل والاسوء من
هذا كله ان تكون هناك موجه تضخم ثاني في
هذه الفتره الموجه الثانيه في هذا الفتره
سوف تكون في فتره السبتمبر لغايه 2020
وفي حال اذا كان هناك موجه ثانيه سوف تقول
الهامش امام السياسه النقديه والمركز
الاوروبي ضيف جدا وبالتالي يمكن ان تؤدي
في مكان ما الى حلقه من الاجور والاسعار
وبالتالي تكون خرجت الامور عن عقالها في
اوروبا وبالتالي نكون دخلنا في مشكله
اقتصاديه سوف تمتد لخمس سنوات مقبله شكرا
جزيلا لك دانيال دكتور دانيال ملحم الباحث
الاقتصادي من باريس تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
ونتابع من تحذير وكاله الامن السيبراني
الامريكيه تقول نقيم الوضع بعد انذار
ايطالي بشان هجوم قرصنه عالميه نقع ايضا
على هذا الموضوع في الملف الايراني وصف
مدير منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه محمود
امير القرار الذي اصدره المرشد بالعفو عن
معتقلي الاحتجاجات بادعائي الذي لا يغير
شيئا ودعا لمحاسبه من امروا بالقمع بدلا
من انتقاء فئات المحتجين المفرز عنهم على
حد وصفه
وبعد وقت قصير من قرار الافراج الذي اصدره
خامنا افادت وسائل اعلام الايرانيه بان
السلطات اعتقلت صحفيه
للاصلاحيين والناس محمد هي شقيقه الصحفيه
الهي محمد المعتقل على خلفيه نشرها خبر
وفاه الفتاه الكرديه محسن اميني التي
اشعلت الاحتجاجات وقتها وفجرتها
وفي الاثناء دعى امير حسين مساوي القيادي
الايراني المعارض والذي يخضع للاقامه
الجبريه منذ فتره طويله دعا الى استفتاء
عام حول كتابه دستور جديد لايران وتشكيل
جمعيه دستوريه من ممثلين حقيقيين لصياغته
واكد مساويا انه لا يعتقد حاليا في فاعليه
النظام الايراني الحالي المعتمد على
المرشد الاعلى
وتقاطعت تصريحات موسوي مع رساله وجهها
الرئيس الاسبق محمد خاتمي لمناسبه الذكرى
الرابعه والاربعين للثوره الخميني حتى
فيها النظام على ضروره الانصياع لتوقعات
ورغبات الشعب وقال ختم ان الاصلاح الذي
اعتمده النظام يمكن القول انه فشل او وصل
الى طريق مسدود معتبرا ان من حق الشعب ان
يخيب امله في هذا الاصلاح كما خاب امله من
النظام الحاكم نفسه
يتحدث عن معارك عنيفه في دوناتسك ويقول ان
الوضع صعب للغايه ويبدو ان الرؤساء
السابقين وعائلاتهم استغلوا فرصه احياء
ذكرى الثوره لبث رسائلهم لكن رساله اسره
الرئيس الايراني الاسبق اعلي اكبر هاشمي
رفسانجاني جاءت مختلفه فعائلته اكدت مقتله
ووصفت وفاته قبل ست سنوات بالمريبه وطالبت
باعاده التحقيق في الوفاه
[موسيقى]
الذكرى السادسه لوفاه الرئيس الايراني
الاسبق اكبر هاشمي رفسا جاني
[موسيقى]
عائله رفسان تؤكد مقتله وان وفاته لم تكن
طبيعيه
فاطمه هاشمي رفسا جاني ابنه رفسنجاني
والدي شهيد وعرج مظلوما
والدي شهيد وعرج مظلوما نحن لا نعيش اياما
جيده ونحن في وضع سيء للغايه والشعب
الايراني مكتئب وحزين ويائس بسبب الازمات
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والاجتماعيه
تسعه يناير 2018
ياسر رفسان نجل الرئيس الاسبق طالب باعاده
التحقيق حول اسباب الوفاه
الخامس عشر من يناير 2022
محسن هاشمي نجلو راسا جاني وفاه والدي
مريبه والنظام اراد اظهار العكس
[موسيقى]
معنى من لندن البحث في الشان الايراني
عارف نصر اهلا بك معنا استاذ عارف مره
جديده في العربيه 360 الى اي مدى تعتقد
بان رسائل الرؤساء السابقين والقياديين
المعارضين السابقين مهمه في هذا السياق
ويمكن ان تحدث فارقا
تحيه طيبه لك استاذ طاهر والمشاهده
العربيه الكرام باحتقادي بان ربما المفرده
التي ممكن ان نستخدمها هي انها انهيار
كبير من داخل النظام
وانتهاء الى مرحله مهمه جدا ربما كان
يتردد الكثيرون في اعلانها وهي انهيار
مفهوم الاصلاحات في ايران بمعنى وخاصه من
من اسس
يعني مفهوم الاصلاحات سواء محمد خاتمي عام
1997 او من الحسين مسوي والذي عرفت باسمه
الحركه الخضراء لذلك انا اعتقد بانه هذا
اول انهيار من داخل النظام ومن داخل
المنظومه التي غادت النظام الايراني
بمرحله حساسه جدا من رئيس وزراء كان نصبه
مؤسس الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الخميني ورئيس
جمهوريه انتخب باعلى نسبه تصويت لذلك انا
اعتقد بان هنالك رمزيه كبيره جدا الى هذه
المرحله
والتي جاءت من غاده الاصلاحات وطلبوا من
خلالها العبور من الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
والتاسيس او
ربما الذهاب الى يعني اصلاحات جذريه لا
تنحد بسقف النظام الحالي وتدعو الى ربما
اسقاط علني الى جمهوريه الاسلاميه لذلك
انا اعتقد بان هنالك رمزيه كبيره
ومصطلحات او الجمل او الدعوات المبادرات
سمها ما شئت اللي بتحس انه فعلا هي خارج
سقف النظام
لانه يعني كل اللي شفناه على الاقل يتحدث
عن تغييرات عن اصلاحات
من هؤلاء شخصيا اقصد يعني من هؤلاء
القيادي شخصيا او من قياديين كبار اولا ثم
النقطه الاخرى كلهم كانوا يقولون ويتحدثون
وهم يعني بعضهم قيد الاقامه الجبريه اصلا
بسبب ما كانوا يطالبون به ولم يستطيعوا ان
يحدثوا
انا اعتقد بان هذا انهيار وربما استخدم
مفهوم الانهيار وانا اعي ذلك اعي ذلك لان
هو يدعو الى العبور من الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه يدعو ويقول بان هنالك فشل
بالجمهوريه الاسلاميه وهو يعترف بانه جزء
من هذا الفشل وهنا اتحدث عن امير الحسين
الموسوي نفس هذا هذه العبارات لكن بنفس
اكثر دبلوماسيه سمعناه من الحسين موسى
وكذلك من سبعه من ابرز غاده الاصلاحات من
من سجن ايفين لذلك انا اعتقد بانه هنالك
رمزيه كبيره الى هذه التصريحات ممكن ان
تحدث فارق بالضمن التيار الذي لا يزال
متمسك بان بالامكان ان يكون هنالك
اصلاحات من داخل النظام لذلك انا اعتقد
هذه الرمزيه هي النتاج الى هذا الصراع
الخطابي الذي كنا نشهده بين المعارضه
والنظام الايراني لكن الان نشهده في داخل
النظام الايراني وربما حتى بعض قضايا
الفساد التي تخرج غالبا او ربما ضد شمخان
وغيرها هي ايضا تشير الى ان حتى بالتيار
الاصولي توجد هذه الخلافات وهي باتت الان
علنيه وواضحه في على الساحه الايرانيه
تسمح لي ان استعرض جانبا اخر في الملف
الايراني قبل ان نعود اليك استاذ عارف
النصر شكرا لا معنا تبقى اذا في الوقت
الذي تنهال فيه الانتقادات على النظام
الايراني كشفت ايران انترناشونال خبايا
جديده عن الحرس الثوري تحديدا عن
ميليشياته في المنطقه حادثه فساد داخل جسم
الذراع القوي للمرشد كشف تفاصيل
النظام كشف النظام او حاول النظام ان
يخفيها طويلا كشفت الان مساعد رئيس
البرلمان الايراني جمال الدين بروماند
استولى على جزء من رواتب الميليشيات في
العراق وسوريا واليمن لكن النظام الايراني
لم يسعى الى محاسبه
ولا محاسبه المشتركين معه في هذا التلاعب
بحسب ايران انترناشونال فان فيلق القدس
التابع للحرس الثوري الايراني لديه اكثر
من 200 الف مقاتل في الشرق الاوسط لكنه
يعلن انهم نصف هذا العدد فقط تحصل ميليشيا
حزب الله اللبناني على اعلى الرواتب بنحو
1300 دولار شهريا مقدمه من النظام
الايراني لكل عنصر مقاتل اما راتب
ميليشيات ايران في سوريا فيبلغ 250 دولارا
بينما ياتي الحوثيون في اليمن في ذيل
القائمه بنحو 100 دولار شهريا لكل مقاتل
استاذ عارف نصر البحث في الشان الايراني
من لندن مجددا ماذا تقول هذه المعلومات
التي تكشفها ايران
اعتقد بان هذه المعلومات مهمه جدا من حيث
اولا تفيد بان هنالك علاقه مصلحيه بين
ربما علاقه مصلحيه بين الحرس الثوري وهذه
الميليشيات وبالتالي هي تقاتل كمرتزقه
وليست جانب عقائدي كما يروج له
النظام الايراني النقطه الثانيه يفيد بشكل
واضح باننا نحن امام الاستراتيجيه التي
ارادها النظام الايراني منذ عام 1979 وهي
قضيه تصدير الثوره لكنما النقطه الثالثه
التي اعتقد بان يجب ابرازها وهي قضيه
الاختلافات الداخليه بين التيار الاصولي
بمعنى بقضيه اعدام علي رضا اكبر التي
شهدناها راينا موضوع علي شمخاني باتا
واضحا وهنالك ارتباط بالتجسس وحتى تكهنات
بان يكون هنالك اقاله
غريبه الى علي شم وهذا الملف ايضا ابرازه
بهذه الفتره ربما ضمن هذه الصراعات
الداخليه على السلطه واعتقد بانها قد يكون
هنالك الملفات اكثر سنشهدها خلال الفتره
الغريبه تمر عاده مثل هذه الملفات
باتهام من هذا النوع مثل الذي تحدثت عنه
ايران انترناشونال عن ابرماند ومشتركين
معه قاموا بهذا التلاعب بالاستيلاء على
جزء من رواتب الميليشيات في العراق وسوريا
واليمن هل تمر هذه الامور عاده وتحصل بدون
تحقيقات الكافيه فقط الاعتبارات مصلحيه
معينه داخل النظام
يعني اذا ما رجعنا الى التسجيل المسرب الى
محمد علي جعفري قائد الحرس الثوري السابق
الذي تحدث عن شريكه ياس الغامضه وحتى
التقارير التي تحدثت عن الفساد الكبير جدا
لغالبان يشير بان هنالك تواطح حتى من
المرشد الايراني مع هؤلاء وبالتالي اعتقد
من بهذه بهذا الظرف وهذه الخلافات
الداخليه
النظام الايراني يسكت عن هذه
الفساد الداخلي ربما بفترات اخرى كما
شاهدنا مع محمد علي
جعفري
ستكون هنالك اقالات كما شاهدنا ذلك مثلا
مع حسين طائب على اثره
التسريب الصوتي الذي خرج او ربما بعض
التغيرات لكن مع ذلك هنالك بعض الرؤوس ذات
القوه بحيث انها تستطيع ان تمر
سالمه او تخرج كلمه من مسلسل داخلي بس كيف
تفسر الاختلاف بالرواتب يعني 1300 دولار
لعنصر مقاتل في حزب الله اللبناني
نتحدث عن 250 دولار
[موسيقى]
للمقاتلين في سوريا
للحوثيين مئه دولار لكل مقاتل فقط
يعني اعتقد بان هذه الرواتب تتعلق بنوعيه
الاهميه وبنوعيه النفوذ الذي احدثه كل طرف
من هذه الاطراف حزب الله عمل
ربما نقطه
اكبر بكثير مما عمله حتى الميليشيات
العراقيه والحوثيه بمعنى انها ربطت الحرس
الثوري بالحزب الله من خلال الزواج
والاسر الواحده بمعنى معظم زوجات
مقاتلي حزب الله هي من الحرس الثوري
والعكس صحيح بما في ذلك قاسم سليماني ابنه
عماد مغنيه هي زوجه قاسم سليمان وبالتالي
هذه المظاهرات التي حدثت بين حزب الله
والحرس الثوري لها تاثير مباشر بنوعيه
الرواتب الاهميه التي تكون بها وحتى
الذوبان الذي شهدناه من حزب الله مع الحرس
الثوري له ايضا هذه الاهميه وا
ربما باقي الميليشيات هي اقل جدا وبالتالي
وفق الاهميه الحرس الثوري يضع الرواتب
والارقام المناسبه لكل طرف من هذه
الميليشيات مع مع اجمدته ومع اهميتها
الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ عارف
ناصر الباحث في الشان الايراني من لندن
تحياتي اليك
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال حسين
يزادان بنى رئيس حزب الحريه الكردستاني
الايراني المعارض ان الحزب سيناضل من اجل
حق اعلان استقلال كردستان عن ايران وسيلجا
لاي وسيله لضمان هذا الحق
ياسيني ودولتي
رقيبه سمحت القوانين الدوليه لكل امه وشعب
بتقرير مصيره يتضمن ذلك ايضا انشاء دوله
واعلان الاستقلال لدينا خبره مئه عام مع
الدوله الفارسيه طوال ذلك الوقت لم نرى اي
فرصه للعيش في ظل قواعد ديمقراطيه مع
طهران اعلان الاستقلال حقنا لاننا امه
وشعب يحق لنا المطالبه بالاستقلال لذلك
نعتقد انه فقط من خلال الاستقلال يمكننا
تحقيق التنميه في بلدنا هذا حقنا ونحن
نناضل من اجل ذلك امثله في كندا واسكتلندا
في بريطانيا امثله جيده للاتفاق مع الدوله
المركزيه من اجل اجراء استفتاء في كردستان
اذا سمحت الحكومه بذلك فهي طريقه
ديمقراطيه ونحن نرحب بهذه الخطوه ولكن اذا
لم يكن ذلك مسموحا به فسنستخدم اي وسيله
اخرى لضمان هذا الحق نحن على ثقه من اننا
سنحقق هذا الهدف
وفي المقابله الخاصه طالب حسين يزداد بنى
الاتحاد الاوروبي بعدم التردد وتصنيف
الحرس الثوري الايراني منظمه ارهابيه
وانتقد في الوقت ذاته تردد الولايات
المتحده واوروبا بهذا الشان
في الواقع سقطت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
بالفعل في اذهان الناس ما ابقى الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه هو العلاقات مع اوروبا والموقف
الضعيف للولايات المتحده ومع ذلك هذا
يتغير لقد غيرت الولايات المتحده موقفها
ولا تريد الدخول في مفاوضات مع ايران ايضا
غير الاوروبيون مواقفهم لان ايران لم تعد
تمتلك ربحا اقتصاديا لاوروبيين وقد ثار
الشعب على النظام نرحب بتصنيف الحرس
الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه لقد تاخرت
كثيرا لكن هذا افضل من عدمه في الوقت نفسه
نشعر ببعض الشك بين الدول الاوروبيه نامل
ان يكونوا واثقين من قرارهم نامل ان يقوم
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاوروبيه بتصنيف
الحرس الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه
[موسيقى]
تتابعنا معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا
المشاركه في الاولمبياد ليست امرا صعبا
اطلاقا لماذا عليك فقط ان ترى الاولمبياد
الهندي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الدفاع التركي
اكار ان الوفود العسكريه لتركيا وسوريا
وروسيا ستعقد اجتماعا الشهر الجاريه وفي
تصريح لصحيفه تركيه اكد اكار ان الاجتماع
ياتي استكمالا للقاء ثلاثي بصيغه سوريا
روسيا تركيا مشيرا في السياق نفسه الى ان
الوفود الفنيه من وزارات الدفاع
والاستخبارات للبلدان الثلاثه ستجتمع وان
الحوار سيستمر غير ان الوزير التركي لم
يقدم تفاصيل اوفى عن موعد الاجتماع المزمع
ومكانه
تحاول السلطات في كوريا الشماليه نشر
مقاطع على موقع يوتيوب عبر مؤثرين محللين
في محاوله لعكس النظره النمطيه عنها
واقناع السياح بان البلاد امنه المزيد في
هذا التقرير
نزهات ضحكات جولات سياحيه واقع وردي تحاول
كوريا الشماليه عكسه عن طبيعه الحياه فيها
من خلال صفحات مؤثرين محليين فما يعرفه
العالم عن هو عزلتها عن العالم الخارجي
وعداوتها مع جارتها الجنوبيه والغرب
والقليل عن حياه سكانها يعرض هؤلاء
المؤثرون عبر منصاتهم لقطات يقال بانها
جزء من اسلوب حياه طبيعيه يعيشه المواطن
في كوريا الشماليه
سينما مسابح مسارح متنزهات ترفيهيه وامور
اخرى قد تكون من المسلمات في اي بلد اخر
لكن ليس وفق ما تعرف عنه حول واقع حيث
الكماليات تعد رفاهيه لفئات محدده الخبراء
يرون بان تلك المقاطع ما هي الا محاوله
تظليليه من قبل السلطات في كوريا الشماليه
بهدف الدفع بالبلد المعزول الاجتماعيا
واقتصاديا وسياسيا وتصويره كبلد امن
للسياح
تحاول كوريا الشماليه تغيير الصوره
النمطيه عنها استغلال حملات دعائيه يقول
محللون بانها وهميه ولا تعكس حقيقه ما
يعانيه الكوريون الشماليون من تضييق وحذر
على تسريب المعلومات للخارج وقيود على
حريه التعبير
فبينما تحرم السلطات الكوريه الشماليه
المواطنين العاديين من الحق في الوصول الى
شبكات التواصل والانترنت الذي يخضع لرقابه
جديده لجانب حرمانهم من الحصول على كتب
وافلام اجنبيه ويتعرض من تضبط معه لعقوبات
مشدده توفره بسخاء لاخرين ولكن بشروط
تقديم صوره ورديه للحياه اليوميه في بيون
جانج عبر منصات تواصل والاداه هنا الشباب
والاطفال روان حمزه العربيه
الفرصه اليوم قوسه يتصدع مبانيه تدهورت
ورساله المعماري طمست حتى المباني من حوله
ترمقه بالنظره ذاتها منذ 60 عاما نظره
حسره معرض رشيد كرامه الدولي في طرابلس
اللبنانيه عاد لدائره الضوء بعد ان ادرجته
اليونسكو في قائمتها للتراث المهدد هذا
المعرض الذي اوقفت الحرب الاهليه نموه وما
زالت مقاعده تشكو من هجر الجمهور وعند احد
المداخل لافته تعبر عن المكنون ممنوع
الدخول المبنى غير امن هذا لبنان الذي لم
تغادر روحه تبعات الحرب الاهليه حتى وان
غادر الحرب
وفي تصريح اليوم الفشل لم يكن خطاي ومؤسسه
اقتصاديه ذات نفوذ عرقله خططي للاصلاح
الاقتصادي هذه شكوى رئيسه الوزراء
البريطانيه السابقه عن اسباب فشلها وعن
تركها للحكومه تروس قالت ايضا ان خطاها
كان الاستخفاف بالمقاومه التي كانت
تواجهها من النظام تجاه سياستها المتعلقه
بالسوق الحره بطبيعه الحال ستخرج
باكثر من مبرر على مدار الوقت لتفسير سبب
نيلها لقب صاحبه اقصر فتره في المقصد
فيديو اليوم من الهند لمن كان يحلم
بالمشاركه في الاولمبياد لكنه يرى
المنافسه صعبه
فيمكنه الان المشاركه في الاولمبياد
القروي الهنديه ولكن فقط ان كنتم تحلمون
برفع الاثقال فالمجال مفتوح امامكم ولكن
المشكله انكم سترفعون الاثقال باذانكم وان
كنتم ترون انفسكم متميزين في العدو فلديكم
الفرصه لاطلاق
سيقانكم بالرياح ولكن سيكون عليكم دفع
اطار شاحنه في الوقت نفسه وان كنتم تشعرون
بانكم قادرون على التحمل فلتجذبوا
باسنانكم دراجه ناريه تسير في عكس الاتجاه
وعليها ثلاثه اشخاص هناك في الاولمبياد
القروي يؤمنون بانهم يضحون باطرافهم من
اجل سمعه الهند لذا ان كنتم ما زلتم
تفكرون فلا داعي
للاولمبياد الهنديه ولا العاديه كذا
[موسيقى]
نكتفي بهذا القدر ولكن نتابع في اولمبياد
الاخبار وماراثون الاخبار الان مع اخبار
الساعه مستمره مع صهيب مساء الخير ماذا
لديك انا مشترك في مره الاخبار ولكن
استبعد فكره المشاركه في هذا الاولمبياد
يا طاهر متعبه صحيح شكرا لك طبعا في
الصداره اوكرانيا والمنطاد الصيني ما يزال
يتصدر الاخبار هذه الليله نتابع بعد قليل
في اخبار الساعه اليك شكرا
[موسيقى]